i think for me it's been
really nice to
just find a new group of people and
friends that i get to go and hang out
with new experiences yeah it's kind of a
new chapter of my life where i get to
focus on really work and friends and
family and just having a lot of fun i
want everyone to be able to achieve
their dreams for themselves no matter
how small or big they may seem this
young lady right here is having quite
the summer i mean a birthday a bow and a
beautiful new fragrance i mean welcome
charlie demilio hello i'm so excited to
talk to you about your fragrance which
by the way smells so good thanks i gotta
tell you happy belated birthday you just
turned 18. yes how does it feel it feels
kind of the same
but
it's been super fun i had to i had a
great celebration with all my friends my
family so it was really really nice i
love it you got some new tattoos that i
hear i did
something tells me these weren't the
first ones though no i
had i think three
before i turned 18. okay and then
i got a few more i think now i have 14.
you have 14 10. yeah i only have the one
they're so tiny are they yeah and they
all have like a special meaning behind
it right yeah yeah are your parents like
no more please no more tattoos
i think that they're happy that they're
so small like most of the time when you
look at me you can't even tell okay so
it's but it's fun when people ask
they're like do you have any tattoos i'm
like yeah i have a bunch and i get to
like go through and it's that's awesome
because most people want like the sleeve
but you're like no i just want some
tattoos for to myself you don't have to
see them and a lot of them are like on
my fingers so you don't really notice
them do you have a favorite one though
um that's tough i would say the ones on
the inside of my feet
you've been doing a lot of cool things
uh but you know what you also did get to
go to prom recently well your dress was
so perfect it was so cute did you have
fun i had so much fun what was it like
for you to like live out that whole
experience because i feel like that's
there was you know not too long ago
there was kids in high school who didn't
get to have prom because of covet yeah i
was super excited that i got to enjoy
prom with my grade and all of my friends
that i went to school with and getting
to
just step back into that teenage high
school
you know group of people that i love so
much was
so perfect and they were all so sweet
and it was such a fun night and then
since then i've gotten to
really reconnect with a lot of those
high school friends that i missed so
much and that's been a wonderful time i
love it now did you bring a date to prom
or did you kind of go as a group
so i went with a friend from high school
it was just
you know a thing where i needed someone
to go with i can't just show up to a
prom of a school i don't go to anymore
um but i got to go with all my best
friends and that was super nice now did
landon feel like he was missing out like
that he didn't get to go to prom with
you um we actually
weren't really
talking when i all went on that was
pre everything else so um
it was just really focused on me going
to prom with all my girlfriends i love
that yeah well now you do have landing
in your life i mean how does how has it
changed your whole like summer and your
whole year yeah um i think for me it's
been
really nice to
just find a new group of people and
friends that i get to go and hang out
with new experiences yeah it's kind of a
new chapter of my life where i get to
focus on really work and friends and
family and just having a lot of fun how
did this even happen yeah
it was actually
just through my my sister okay
shout out to dixie
dixie's always uh making sure that i'm
in the loop on everything and it just
kind of happened out of nowhere so funny
because people are already calling you
guys a mini
kravis you guys
you guys please not french kids
no fridge kissing baby okay great dinner
love you everybody i love you
have you had a chance to hang out with
courtney and travis at all um they are
the sweetest people in the world yeah i
feel like you know the barkers of course
are no strangers to reality tv any
chance we could see landon pop up in
season two of your show um i guess you
guys are just gonna have to walk okay
being normal kids that doesn't change
with following
i still have to make my best
we're the familiar
uh you know obviously you have done so
much in a short amount of time really
but what's like on your list like what's
on your bucket list your life goals and
maybe not even related to like business
but like do you want to go to college
for example um i think for me right now
it's kind of developing those goals and
dreams that are
going to happen when i
finish off my teenage years in my early
20s and kind of figuring out what's
important to me but as of right now it's
definitely
trying new things that i think people
wouldn't expect from me
but also just focusing on having fun and
staying grounded i am a boring dreamer
we are all born dreamers
let's talk about this new fragrance born
dreamer talk to me about the inspiration
behind the name of this line we were
brainstorming a little bit and we landed
on born dreamer and i just felt like it
was so perfect there's a story with this
one and i really love that about the
fragrance tell me about how does it vibe
with your personal chemistry what does
that mean yeah i think for me
i
now have a signature smell but the way
it smells on me is different than it
smells on my best friend
and i feel like that adds its own little
uniqueness and individuality to the
fragrance but also to each person and i
really love that about it so what does
charlie demilio smell like i would say
the
pear
jasmine
a little bit of the musk just all
together it's very clean i noticed
myself reapplying a lot throughout the
day
because that pear is just
you really can't beat it and it's a
little sweet but not too sweet it's very
it's very safe for every occasion and i
love that about it gosh did you ever
imagine that you would have a fragrance
one day absolutely it's so cool yeah
yeah could there be more down the line
like a makeup line skin care i would
love to do more with that and there's
been you know some stuff going on behind
the scenes
but i would love to be able to expand
this into
making all of the things that i love
yeah i could see you doing a skincare
line because i also love that in your
photos i mean most of them are like
filter free you know i mean do you hope
that other kind of content creators will
follow suit and be a little more
authentic in that sense i think it's
very individual to the person someone
that
enjoys what i do and how i post my
photos and present myself on social
media might not like other people that
look picture perfect all the time but
some people love that picture perfect
look and sometimes
i look a little crazy and i play into
that but i think it's really individual
to each person but i have been open
about the things
in my life um in that way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why don't you
[Music]
[Music]
lose say mind
[Music]
[Music]